Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters. Welcome to another episode of Cutters Clinic Live.
I have a special guest, Alan Cash, with us from Terra Biologicals. He is, um, how I found out
about your company. Alan was, um, I had a maybe 10, 12 years ago, um, your bedadine product, which
you'll talk about what oxaloacetate is. And I'll let you get into the scientific ins and outs of it.
I, we've just found it to be a great product for our members. A lot of our members are taking it.
Um, and I just, I thought, you know, last time I placed an order with you, I just crossed
I was like, I've never had you on our podcast. So I gotta let you introduce yourself and your company
and, um, we'll just have a chat. I'm, uh, Alan Cash, uh, with Terra Biological. Uh, we started
this company, um, back in 2006, uh, when we started examining, uh, the use of oxaloacetate
as a method to mimic calorie restriction. And when we, we did this at UCSD, um, through the Williams
laboratory, uh, David Williams is now up at UCLA. And, uh, what we saw is when we gave oxaloacetate to
small animals, short-lived animals, they lived anywhere from 25 to 50% longer. And they're just
aren't a lot of things that, that do that. Um, the reason we were able to do that is we were
uh, following the molecular pathways that are involved in calorie restriction.
And primarily looking at, uh, AM, uh, PK activation. Uh, so your genes are pretty much the same
all the time. Your DNA doesn't change all that much. But depending upon the environment, what you
eat, the stresses that you're under, your current health, um, and medications that you take, uh, your
genes can turn on or turn off. Uh, your DNA can turn on new proteins and express those proteins
throughout your body. And one of the things that calorie restriction does is it turns on about
10% of your genome, uh, to make different proteins. And we found these proteins to be very beneficial to
health. Um, one of the ways that throughout the animal kingdom that we can get animals to live longer,
to have less inflammation, to have less chronic disease is with calorie restriction. So being able to
turn on the same process in your body may be a very good health strategy. And this is what we
originally set out to do with our product benagine, uh, which is oxaloacetate, uh, capitol.
Um, so we introduced those back in, uh, 2009 after quite a bit of, uh, testing, uh, and
notifications to the FDA of a new dietary ingredient, oxaloacetate. And since then we've gotten
just a ton of great feedback. Um, one of the things that we saw is, um, women who were taking
benagine, uh, through their doctor, uh, reported that their symptoms of PMS just went away. And
being a guy, I didn't realize how important that was. Um, but these women quickly
gave me the, the notice that it was there. First of all, are you married, Alan?
Yes, I am. And I had bad issues with that ever. Well, like I said, I have three daughters that
I've evolved in through that issue. And, uh, certainly it's, it's helped my, uh, family. Um, and what
we saw is when we gave oxaloacetate to women with emotional, uh, PMS, uh, as opposed to the physical
symptoms, there, there are a lot of things on the market for physical PMS, uh, like, you know,
the, the selling, the, uh, bloating, the, uh, you know, aches and pains, that type of thing, uh, acne.
But there's almost nothing on the market for emotional symptoms, uh, such as, you know, sadness,
irritability, anger, uh, important things that, that affect their, um, relationships and their
ability to get along with others. And what they were reporting back to me is that when these symptoms
went away, I mean, one woman put it very succinctly to me. She said, since I was 13 years old,
I've had to hide from my work colleagues, from my husband, from my children, for three days,
every month, because if I didn't, I wouldn't have those things anymore. Wow. This is the first time
I'm 36 years old. This is the first time all of those things just went away. And what we did
track it, uh, to a really unusual set of circumstances, oxaloacetate, uh, goes into the stomach and then
goes to the liver. And it, uh, allows, uh, the processing of fatty acids into glucose so that you
can feed your, your heart and your brain during times of shortage. And when we look at women with,
uh, extreme mood swings in PMS, uh, using functional MRI. And this was done up at the UCLA.
Um, what we see is in the cerebellum, which is in the back of the brain, it's kind of,
sometimes it's referred to the primitive part of the brain or the animal part of the brain.
But what we see is during that time period where this emotions just go all over the place is the
need for huge amounts of glucose in that area of the brain. It's a genetic thing. And it seems to
affect between 30 and 40% of the women that are out there. And if you don't get that glucose,
that's when there's a problem. And it's the same thing for men. They call it being hangry. I,
I experience it myself when I haven't, you know, I missed a meal and all of a sudden something irritates
me. I'm hungry. I'm irritable. Um, it's a common response, not just with women. So what we saw is the
oxaloacetate balances the blood sugar, enabling these women to avoid the shortage of glucose.
And it's interesting. This is why these women seek out chocolate. They seek out
carbohydrates, you know, chips and, and any, you know, pasta, anything to give them a rush of sugar.
The problem with carbohydrates is that you then get an insulin surge and your glucose levels
crater in about 30 minutes, and it makes the problem worse. And so what we see with oxaloacetate is
it increases something called the NAD to NADH ratio in the cells. This activates a signaling
molecule called AMP protein-activated kinase or AMPK. An AMPK then works with the nucleus
to put out certain proteins that help stabilize blood sugar all the time. It also works in the liver
to allow the processing of fatty acids to glucose so that in times of shortage, again,
you can feed your heart and you feed your brain. And this has made the problem so much better.
We did a clinical trial, uh, double blinded, placebo controlled, cross-over trial, gold standard.
We saw amazing results. And we saw more than a 50% drop in sadness. We saw a 50% drop in anxiety,
in related stress. We even saw a 48% reduction in suicidal IVation, which is obviously this product
is going to save some lives. And so that's one thing, that's jubulence. And then as a run-on from this,
we got reports back from our customer base. Hey, I'm not fatigued anymore. Hey, I'm feeling
I have a lot more energy. And this makes sense for a variety of centers. So we wondered if higher doses
of oxaloacetate could help in various fatigue states. For instance, in chronic fatigue or in long
COVID fatigue. And we just finished a clinical trial in both long COVID and chronic fatigue syndrome.
And some of these people with chronic fatigue syndrome had had a CFS for up to 30 years.
Once you get it, it's very hard to get rid of it. These are people that aren't just tired.
If they do any exercise at all, it exhausts them, walking to the mailbox and back,
may put them in bed for a week. Okay, very serious. And I wasn't aware that this was even going on,
but apparently the Center for Disease Control states that there are about 2.5 million people
just in the US with chronic fatigue syndrome. Serious, serious chronic fatigue syndrome,
like you're talking about. Serious chronic fatigue syndrome. Serious fatigue.
So do you think the mechanism of action with chronic fatigue is about the glucose balancing?
We think it's a variety of things. And it's really a complex situation. What we believe and what
others believe based on the papers that have been published is that it's how you produce the energy.
So in your cell, you've got your cell and you've got your nucleus, and then there are these
little organelles called mitochondria, which are like the power plants of your cells.
You put in sugar, which is the fuel that fuels mitochondria. The mitochondria burn the fuel
with oxygen, and they make ATP, which is the energy currency that allows your cells to do all the
things that it does. Now in people with chronic fatigue syndrome, their energy production is less
from the mitochondria and more from something called fermentation. In the cytosol, the might be the
glucose, the sugar, turns into pyruvate. And then that pyruvate is fermented without oxygen
into lactate, which is a common product of milk. And this lactate then is exported out of the cell
and feeds other cells that can use it for energy, but it's a very inefficient process.
And it leads to a lot of free radicals. These are little compounds that are charged,
and they seek to end that charge, and they end up attaching to various proteins and other parts of
the cell, and it causes problems. It can even damage your DNA. So this is what is referred to
by listeners as the warberg effect. Exactly. And it can be a cause, and you will for
other serious diseases that we don't want to mention. Yeah, so auto warberg back in the 1930s is a
German scientist, a brilliant biochemist, and he found the warberg effect primarily by studying
cancer cells. And he felt that the warberg effect was one of the primary things we see in cancer,
at least in solvittumer cancer. And so we see this in cancer cells, but we also see this in chronic
fatigue syndrome patients. Now, we've been doing a lot of work with Houston Methodist
looking at oxaloacetate as it goes into the cell. And what happens? And one of the things we use
to look at that is glioblastoma cells, which is brain cancer cells. And we've been able to show
that oxaloacetate, when you expose the cells to oxaloacetate, the cell brings in the oxaloacetate,
and it reverses the warberg effect. So instead of putting out all this lactate and then feeding other
parts of the cells that need the lactate to grow in a non-oxygen environment, oxaloacetate pushes
these cells back towards normal conditioning, which is really a huge thing right now.
So then they're not using lactic acid as their fuel source anymore.
One of the things that we've been researching, there's a gene called the HIF-1 gene,
that is what converts lactic acid, the pyruvic acid, to get it into the crem cycle. And we found
that our members that have a lot of defects on that gene are more prone to the warberg effect,
with feeding cancer, feeding, chronic fatigue, other diseases. So that's where oxaloacetate is
really the huge beneficial piece to that puzzle. Yeah, and there's been some published work
showing that hypoxia inducible factor one, HIF-1, is actually blocked by oxaloacetate.
Yeah, pretty cool stuff, right? So this all interweaves together, which makes it
more complicated of course, but we're using this oxaloacetate now to help people with fatigue,
to turn their energy system, which has been pushed into the wrong direction,
push it back towards normal. We call it normalization of metabolism. And when we do that,
we see people that have had fatigue for 30 years, all of a sudden, after six weeks of taking
high doses of oxaloacetate, we see their fatigue at least 25% less.
We see people who have had long COVID, who haven't been in this alternate energy state for as long.
We see their fatigue levels dropped by up to 48% in six weeks. And it's so necessary at this time.
I mean, if you look at the numbers of people who have gotten COVID, and then look at the number
of people who are still experiencing events from COVID, it's crazy. It's like we've got the
zombie apocalypse out there. And you know, these people are having trouble at work. They're having
trouble driving, which makes it dangerous for all of us. And they're just, they're wondering,
what can I do to get over this? And one of the things that we've been looking at is how
this chronic fatigue from COVID turns into chronic fatigue syndrome after six months. And they
get stuck in this. And so we're able to have a medical food. So you have to work with your doctor
for this because it's very high dosage, oxaloacetate. Our benignine product gives 100 milligrams of
oxaloacetate per capsule. Our medical food gives 500 milligrams and suggests that you need to take
two to six of these a day. So you're looking at 2,000 to 3,000 milligrams a day on average that these
patients are taking for six weeks in order to get it into the cells and reprogram those cells into
a different energy profile. It is amazing. We have been selling a lot of your products. You know,
we have had just a lot of good feedback to talk about, you know, long haul COVID,
beat a piece of this cause, but there are so many causes. You think of chronic Lyme disease to West
Nile, to other chronic mold issues. People can't even put their finger on what was the cause. They
just have these horrible fatigue symptoms, though, that quite honestly, so many doctors haven't
believed them. And they've been labeled as hypochondriacs. And their family is disowned them,
and their lives have just been extremely disrupted, and it all has to do with the ability to produce
energy the way we're supposed to produce energy in an efficient way and being able to live your life.
Yeah. Yeah. I heard from one patient that had, and by the way, I need to qualify all this.
I am not a medical doctor. I'm a physicist. That's why I'm looking at energy.
But so don't take anything I say as medical advice. Our Benagine product is a nutritional supplement
that's meant to keep healthy people healthy, which it does quite well. Our medical food is for
people with chronic fatigue syndrome. You work with your doctor on that because it's higher dosage.
And we don't have a drug form of oxalo-available yet. We are in clinical trials right now for
cancer-related fatigue at UCLA. We're doing clinical trial work there. We're doing glial blastoma
with the Mayo Clinic. And we're doing other fatigue-related diseases like ALS at the University
of Kansas, but none of that is available yet. That's all in the future. And hopefully the trials
continue to provide us with encouraging results. But for right now, if you have chronic fatigue syndrome,
or if your long COVID has gone more than six months and are now in the chronic fatigue syndrome
category, we have something for you. And it's important to get the word out about that.
Yeah. Well, I thank you for your work. I thank you for coming on today. We'll have you back. I
really want to have you back with some of these other trials. Get through and that we can
legally talk about some other serious diseases as well. So the meantime, you can find
Mr. Cash's products that benefit you and the oxalo acetate CFS on our store. And contact us if
you have questions about those. So thank you again. I appreciate all of you. Thank you so much.
And looking forward to our continued relationship. Absolutely.